why do we have a super moon where the
moon appears larger okay first I gotta
nip this in the bud okay don't get me
started
I'm getting you start don't get me
started get you started here all right
so we there's something called the super
moon okay I don't know who first called
it a super moon all right
I don't know but if you have a 16-inch
pizza would you call that a super pizza
compared with a 15-inch pizza I how many
meat toppings and we're talking cuz if
we're talking like totally loaded then
yes I'm going yes and is the cheese in
the crust right right she's in the crust
because super moon is a 16 inch pizza
compared with a 15 inch pizza it's a
slightly bigger moon I ain't using the
adjective so super moon nah excuse me
that's like super Tuscan I'm not going
there Super Tuscan wines right yes yes
they're super because they're super
price that cost like four or five times
regular you may pay like 100 bucks so
there is no super moon so the super moon
is the moon's orbit around the Earth is
not a perfect circle sometimes it's
closer sometimes it's farther away
that's it and every month there's a
moment when it's closest that's
occasionally that moment when it's
closest coincides with a full moon
people are calling that a super moon
like but they're super half moons
alright there's not every month as a one
of those phases right is the closest I
don't have people that Oh super Crescent
super happy super no no don't get I told
you don't get me started not only that I
wish I was going to tweet this while
we're saying here and now first go ahead
do you know the full moon has no higher
tidal effect on earth than any other
phase of the Moon magaz just making
stuff up